i'm a big fan of coffee and caffeine
and i've been
especially the last few days consuming a
very large amount
and i'm cognizant of the fact that
my body is affected by caffeine
different than
the anecdotal information that other
people tell me
i seem to be not at all affected by it
it's almost
um
it feels like more like a ritual than it
is a chemical boost to my performance
like i can drink several cups of coffee
right before bed and just knock out
anyway
i'm not sure if that's a biological
chemical or it has to do with just the
fact that i'm just consuming huge
amounts of caffeine all that to say
uh
what do you think is the relationship
between coffee and sleep caffeine and
sleep there's an interesting distinction
there there is a distinction so i think
the first thing to say which is going to
sound strange coming from me
is drink coffee
the health benefits associated with
drinking coffee are really quite well
established now
but
i think that the counterpoint to that
well firstly the dose and the timing
make the poison and i'll perhaps come
back to that in just a second
but for
coffee
it's actually not the caffeine
so
you know a lot of people have asked me
about this rightful paradox between the
fact that sleep provides all of these
incredible health benefits
and then coffee which can have a
deleterious
impact on your sleep has
a whole collection of health benefits
many of them venn diagram overlapping
with those that sleep provides how on
earth can you reconcile those two
and the answer is that
well the answer is very simple it's
called
antioxidants
but it turns out that for most people in
western civilization because of diet not
being quite what it should be
the major source through which they
obtain antioxidants is the coffee bean
so the the humble coffee bean has now
been asked to carry the astronomical
weight
of serving up the large majority of
people's antioxidant needs
and
you can see this if for example you look
at the health benefits of decaffeinated
coffee it has a whole constellation of
really great health benefits too so it's
not like caffeine and that's why i liked
what you said
this sort of separation of church and
state between coffee and caffeine it's
not the caffeine it's the coffee bean
itself that provides those health
benefits but
coming back to how it impacts sleep it
impacts sleep in probably at least three
different ways
the first is that for most people
caffeine can make it obviously a little
harder to fall asleep
caffeine can make it harder to stay
asleep but let's say that you are one of
those individuals and i think you are
and you can say look i can have three or
four espressos with dinner and i fall
asleep just fine and i stay asleep
soundly across the night so there's no
problem
the downside there is that even if that
is true the amount of deep sleep that
you get will not be as deep and so you
will actually lose somewhere between 10
to 30 percent of your deep sleep if you
drink caffeine in the evening so to give
you some context to to drop your deep
sleep by let's say 20 i'd probably have
to age you by 15 years or you could do
it every night with a cup of coffee
i think the fourth component that is
perhaps less well understood about
coffee is its timing and that's why i
was saying the timing and the dose make
the poison the dose by the way once you
get past about three cups of coffee a
day the health benefits actually start
to turn down in the opposite direction
so there is a u-shaped function it's
sort of you know the goldilocks syndrome
not too little not too much just the
right amount
the second component is the timing
though caffeine has a half-life of about
five to six hours
meaning that after five to six hours
fifty percent of that on average for the
average adult is still in the system
which means that it has a quarter life
of 10 to 12 hours so in other words if
you have a coffee at noon a quarter of
that caffeine is still circulating in
your brain at midnight
so having a cup of coffee at noon one
could argue is the equivalent of tucking
yourself into bed at midnight and before
you turn the light out you swig a
quarter of a cup of coffee
but that doesn't still answer your
question as to why are you so immune so
i'm someone who is actually
unfortunately very sensitive to caffeine
and if i have you know even two cups of
coffee in the morning
um i i don't sleep as well that night
and i
find it miserable because i love the
smell of coffee i love the routine i
love the ritual i think i would love to
be invested in it it's just terrible for
my sleep so i switched to decaf there is
a difference from one individual to the
next and it's controlled by a set of
liver enzymes called
cytochrome p450 enzymes and there is a
particular gene
that if you have a different sort of
version of this gene it's called cyp
1 a 2
that gene will determine the speed of
the clearance of caffeine from your
system
some people will have a version of that
gene that is very effective and
efficient at clearing that caffeine and
so their half-life could be as short as
two hours rather than five to six hours
other people
hands up matt walker um have a version
of that gene that is not very effective
at clearing out the uh the caffeine and
therefore the half-life
sort of sensitivity could be somewhere
between you know eight to nine hours
so we understand that there are
individual differences but overall i
guess the
top line here is
drink coffee um and understand that it's
not the caffeine it's the coffee that's
the benefit and the dose makes the
poison is there some aspect to it that's
it's like a muscle
in terms of the
all the combination of letters and
numbers that you just said is there some
aspect that if um
i can improve
the quarter life the half-life
can decrease that number if i just
practice
like i drink a lot of coffee so like
habit
alters how your body is able to get rid
of the caffeine not how the body is able
to get rid of the caffeine but it does
alter how sensitive
the body is to the caffeine and it's not
at the level of the enzyme degrading the
caffeine it's at the level of the
receptors that caffeine will act upon
now it turns out that those are called
adenosine receptors and maybe we can
speak about what adenosine is and sleep
pressure and all of that good stuff but
as you start to drink more and more
coffee
the body tries to fight back and it
happens with many different drugs by the
way and it's called tolerance
and so one of the ways that your body
becomes tolerant to a drug is that the
receptors that the drug is binding to
these sort of welcome sites these sort
of you know picture myths as it were
that receive the drug
those start to get
taken away from the surface of the cell
and it's what we call receptor
internalization
so the cell starts to think gee where's
you know this there's a lot of
stimulation going on this is too much so
i'm just going to
when normally i would you know coat my
cell with let's just say five of these
receptors for argument's sake
things are going a little bit too
ballistic right now i'm going to take
away at least two of those receptors and
down scale it to just having three of
those
and now you need two cups of coffee to
get the same effect that one cup of
coffee got you before
and that's why then when you go
cold turkey on coffee all of a sudden
the system has equilibriated itself to
expecting x amount of stimulation and
now all of that stimulation is gone so
it's now got too few receptors and you
have a caffeine withdrawal syndrome
and that's why for example with you know
drugs of abuse things like heroin when
people go into abstinence
you know as they're sort of moving into
their addiction
they will build up a progressive
tolerance to that drug so they need to
take more of it to get the same high
but then if they go cold turkey
for some period of time the system goes
back to being more sensitive again it
starts to repopulate the surface of the
cell with these receptors but now when
they reuse and they fall off the wagon
if they go back to the same dose that
they were using before
you know 10 weeks ago or three months
ago
that dose
can kill them they can have an overdose
even though they were using the same
amount at those two different times
the difference is that it's not the dose
of the drug it's the sensitivity of the
system and that's the same thing that we
see with caffeine in terms of training
the muscle as it were is the system
becomes less sensitive can calibrate
is there a time
the number of hours before bed
that's a a safe bet
to most people to recommend
you shouldn't drink caffeine this many
hours
like is there an average half-life that
you should be aiming at
yeah or is this advice kind of
impossible because there's so much
variability there is a huge variability
and i think everyone themselves you know
to a degree knows it although i'll put a
caveat on that too because it's slightly
dangerous point
so the recommendation for the average
adult and who where is the average adult
in society there is no such thing but
for the average adult
it would be probably cutting yourself
off maybe 10 hours you know before so
assuming a normative bedtime in society
i would say try to stop drinking
caffeine you know
before 2 pm and just keep an eye out you
know and if you're struggling with sleep
dial down the caffeine and see if it
makes a difference
you